Brian a balding her on the show how are
you Baldy hello rich
I'm doing great very good to be with you
I'm good so we've been having fun here
with the bolt come up with your own
personal bowl game it's got to be the
last place you shopped plus the last
thing you ate and that's your bowl game
can you tell me Brian
what's the brine balding or bowl the
last place I shot rich and the first
name of whoa I'm sorry I thought you
dropped off it's the last place you
shopped and the last thing you ate is
your ball game okay I'll take Apple meat
ball game
the Apple meat ball game rich so yes
iPhones that Apple a couple days ago for
some yes and I had a meatball sandwich
for lunch so an apple meatball Apple
well actually it's Apple meatball
sandwich Bowl I like it I wonder what
the trophy would look like fantastic
what do you make a Nate Peterman being
signed by the Raiders Brian I mean is
there what you're seeing on out of
Oakland showing you that maybe Gruden is
is is Derek cars next on his hit list
here well I mean Nathan Peter moon is
just waiting the phone's nest
interception that's why I got shipped
out of Buffalo I mean I never saw
anybody throw interceptions at that rate
right but Shagun did take that
interception bug out of Derek Carr I
mean had until an interception in eight
weeks so maybe he feels like he could do
the same thing to Nathan Peterman and
turn him into a player I guess what I I
mean from what I saw on it with the
whole country salt we need some Peterman
in Buffalo was just a disaster
yeah I know I mean I guess I you know I
wasn't planning on asking you that but
that's just the news that just broke
here and then out of New York you know
because we talked with Peter King and
our one about the the quarterback market
that's coming up and who might be
available which teams might be in and
Pat Shermer said just a yesterday that
he thinks Eli could be of their
quarterback for years to come what are
you seeing out of New York in this
offense as they get to go into the
non-playing season I'm seeing a
quarterback that is very hot and cold
which we've seen him so you know take on
Tampa and Houston so hardly a single
incompletion and then last week he was
under 50% completion and he was erratic
as can be the ball was all over the
place so typically when quarterbacks or
athletes begin to decline that's what
you get you get very inconsistent
performances they can't maintain just a
steady performance from week to week and
that's what I think that you're going to
get some he lied so you're any good days
where you put the ball right on the
money and throw the ball right through
the tire and then he's going to have
days where he's just going to be sailing
it over people's head so would you make
the move well have you been asking me if
I could take Derek Carr and plug him
into the New York office I would do that
absolutely I mean I one thing I like
about Derek Carr and one reason why he
won the job by the way that's what he is
that guy is an attack blown all the time
he's got a big-time arm he plays without
a lot of fear
you know I if you asked him to make five
different reads on a progression he's
not going to do that but you know if
you're gonna ask him to go through one
to two and maybe to three he can do that
and he'll attack you and he'll attack
deep down the field and he's he'll throw
the ball over the middle of fátima
sphere and I would plug in that office
with the weapons they have right now
Brian balding are here on the Rich Eisen
show what was the quote that inspired
our poll question today Chris asked
asked ative brian balding are there yeah
Adrian Phillips from the Chargers baldie
said that artist Patrick mahomes and
Lamar Jackson were equally dangerous but
do you agree with that assessment
is the most dangerous player in the
league right now cuz he can throw the
ball I mean we've watched it every week
now and we don't see any kind of decline
in his performance lamar is dangerous in
that nobody has been able to stop that
offense so far in five weeks
and so he's dangerous on that aspect but
i think they're gonna see the best test
that they sing with elite athletes on
the other side this this Saturday
when they see the Chargers and they see
Melvin Ingram Bosa Derwent James I think
you might have a little different you
know success this week than what he's
had in the last five Saints or one went
away from having home field advantage in
the NFC go through the Superdome Brian
balding earn a me the NFC team that
gives him the most trouble when January
hits do you think well I think you know
teams that can defend him I mean Dallas
has already defended them and we see
what they can do in Chicago can't defend
them I mean you're going to ask about
teams that can get a pass to us with the
front floor that can man up on the
outside with good quarterback play you
got linebackers that can run all day
both teams have that and so I would say
both those teams can go into New Orleans
and give them a hard time since we've
seen it once already but which one do
you think can beat him or do you think
the Saints are gonna go to the Super
Bowl unless you think the Rams are gonna
be able to write the ship that has not
clearly been the same since the 54:51
Monday nighter no no and you know
defensively they have to be good though
rich either they can run the ball
against all year the Eagles play the
ball right through them so I don't know
I don't I don't know if the one and done
yet but you know I think Shaun McVeigh
is looking for answers right now it's a
little late in the season looking for
answers
the quarterback needs to kind of be
righted as well he has not been accurate
the last few weeks
ah-hoo who can go into New Orleans and
and win right now I played in New
Orleans which in a playoff game one time
and I was the left guard right next to
Randall Cunningham and I didn't hear one
word he said all days I mean you know
you talk about when you get to the
playoffs
everything gets ratcheted up speed of
the game the intensity of the crowds get
ratcheted up I that is going to be a
near-impossible place to go in their
play right now in January was that the
old Ricky that resented the old back in
the day of Pat's willing Dome Patrol
except back in the Ricky Jackson
yes exactly who it was and that was you
know Ricky Jackson and that's willing
and all of those cats and for some
reason Jim Moore are calling off the
dogs in the second half and stop
blitzing and we got a chance to come
back and win that game lately
and then the AFC how do you break that
down Brian with what you're seeing on
your film and what you think can be had
in January and what is portable from the
regular season to the postseason which
team do you think makes Super Bowl 53
well the Chargers rinsed have just gone
into Pittsburgh and they've gone into
Kansas City and they have won the
quarterback is you cannot be you can't
bother that guy in any way right now I
mean he's on fire as competitive as they
come I don't know how he's done it over
15 years but he looks even younger than
he did a few years ago and just as fiery
as ever he probably has the best
receiving corps in the league to throw
to and open on the course of the last
three weeks they've been playing without
Melvin Gordon and he's gonna ventually
come back so they look to me like what
they after what they did to Kansas City
last service like that they're gonna be
the most dangerous team Moses got fresh
legs Ingram is an incredible athlete
Turley James is a star and they've got a
star quarterback they look like they're
the team compete right now in the AFC
Brian appreciate the time man
I always appreciate our chats and follow
Baldy at Baldy be a ldy NFL for some of
the best breakdowns you'll see anywhere
really appreciate it Brian thank you
guys we got it we can YouTube Baldy
that's Brian balding or the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience